si vous êtes ici c'est peut-être que
vous faites partie des 50% des français
qui ont du mal à dormir il vous est
difficile de vous détendre avant de vous
coucher vous cogiter en pensant à votre
journée à votre emploi du temps du
lendemain
il existe pourtant une solution
naturelle qui a fait ses preuves depuis
des générations
l'utilisation des plantes le fit aux
nuits en sachet à infuser un mélange
innovant de mélatonine l'hormone
naturelle du sommeil et de cinq plants
vous aide à vous endormir et bien dormir
alors ne pensez plus à rien et profiter
de cette séance de relaxation en
partenariat avec feed aux nuits le
figaro présente inspiration un podcast
de benjamin lubinski psy hypnothérapeute
ou youtube heure lors du précédent
épisode d'inspiration j'ai eu le plaisir
d'accueillir xavier dorison qui est un
scénariste remarquable il a scénarisé
notamment les brigades du tigre au
cinéma et c'est aussi et surtout un
scénariste de bande dessinée acquis
endroits de véritables petites
merveilles comme le troisième testament
le château des animaux
et puis également un épisode de thorgal
cette série cultissime que tout le monde
connaît je crois ou à peu près et l'une
des questions que je posais l'un des
sujets que nous avons aimé aborder
ensemble c'est celui de la créativité
d'où vient l'inspiration comment la
stimuler comment la faire venir parce
que c'est un auteur prolifique et
comment fait-on pour laisser jaillir de
son inconscient des idées des formes des
idées nouvelles
alors moi je crois que la plupart des
artistes des auteurs finalement se
mettre dans un état de transe comme
celui de l'hypnose si en tout cas ce que
pense et aldous huxley qu'un doigt le
meilleur des mondes et qui avait
travaillé un livre avec milton erickson
un psychiatre réputé pour son
utilisation de l'hypnose et vu que
heureusement ce livre a été détruit
sinon je pense que ça va faire un petit
chef-d'oeuvre
donc on se met dans un état modifié de
conscience et c'est là que j'ai eu
l'inspiration et
c'est certainement cet état modifié de
conscience qu'on appelle le mu et
aujourd'hui on va faire en sorte de
pouvoir finalement appelé la muse à
volonté dès que vous en avez besoin dès
que vous en avez envie
je vais vous inviter à fixer un point
peu importe lequel vous aurez remarqué
que lorsqu'on est saisi par une
inspiration
lorsque l'on rêve est bien souvent le
regard se perd
il focalise sur un point et en même
temps il ya une sorte de brouillard qui
apparaît et cet état de rêverie c'est un
état de transe le même que celui de
libéraux zh simplement dans l'hypnose on
le crée on intensifie à volonté et on
apprend aussi surtout à le renforcer l
développer deux séances en ciel en si
c'est pour ça que des séances comme
celles ci sont très intéressantes
lorsqu'on les utilise sur une base
quotidienne
on apprend d'une certaine manière faire
de l'auto hypnose et à laisser venir
l'inspiration
parce que l'inspiration c'était
évidemment pas quelque chose que l'on
force plus on essaie d'être créatifs et
plus on se retrouve avec une page
blanche alors fixé ce point comme une
manière de commencer cette rêverie
c'est moi qui vais vous accompagner dans
cette rêverie et ma voix deviendra le
décor les sons autour de vous elle
prendra part écrire à votre univers
intérieur main dans la main avec votre
inconscient et vous n'avez aucun effort
à faire
l'idée c'est de laisser venir à soi que
ce soit l'hypnose ou la créativité
et cela devient de plus en plus facile
on peut importe le moment vos yeux se
fermeront dans un état de transe
peu importe aussi la profondeur dans
laquelle vous irez la profondeur de
transe
et puis surtout peu importe les mots les
phrases que vous allez oublier le but
justement c'est de décrocher de
l'extérieur de la réalité quotidienne
pour pouvoir rêver des choses plus belle
plus grande plus intense finalement de
s'abstraire de l'extérieur pour stimuler
renforcer son univers intérieur mais
cela ne demande aucun effort juste à
écouter ma voix comme si je vous disais
une histoire et c'est d'ailleurs souvent
lorsqu'on lit lorsque l'imagination est
ensemencée par la littérature ou bien
par la musique
lorsque finalement l'inconscient
rencontre l'art la culture c'est souvent
à ce moment que naissent les plus belles
idées d'un moment de rêverie entre deux
pages d'un moment de rêverie entre deux
morceaux de musique d'un moment de
rêverie tout simplement
5 et tandis que vous fixez ce point qui
peut être va pouvoir se troubler alors
que votre conscient écoute ma voile que
votre inconscient déjà chemine vers une
sorte d'intériorisation et bien cela se
traduit par des choses simples
c'est la respiration qui devient plus
profond plus lente et c'est toujours
comme ça lorsque on est dans ses pensées
lorsque l'on réfléchit intensément ou
lorsque l'on rêve les yeux ouverts
la respiration devient profonde et lente
c'est un processus tout naturel
l'hypnose la créativité
c'est quelque chose que vous connaissez
déjà et le travail que nous allons faire
aujourd'hui va simplement révélé
réveiller dynamiser cette capacité qui
existent en vous la capacité à créer de
nouvelles idées de nouvelles formes
cette capacité merveilleuse qui fait de
nous des créateurs en puissance c'est
simplement le fait de se laisser porter
comme ça par la voix eh bien je menais
de plus en plus vers la transe et ce à
votre rythme et c'est très bien
et pour aller un pas plus avant vers ce
territoire de la créativité de
l'intériorité
vous allez prendre deux inspirations
profondes
comme si vous apprêtiez à plonger dans
un monde différent un monde intérieur
comme ça très bien
et pendant que vos pensées s'accroche et
se décrochent tandis que le corps d'un
côté se détend et que l'esprit lui se
met à son rythme à rêver au rythme lent
des mots et des images des sons et des
sensations qu'il crée en vous alors même
que les pensées se forment se déforme et
que de ce chaos apparent mais pourtant
un ordre celui d'une imagination d'une
histoire d'une sensation d'une musique
d'un sont d'un ressenti d'un sentiment
vous entrez encore plus en transe et
comme c'est agréable de sentir cet air
calme et frais ne dit on pas qu'elle en
ait inspiré inspiration justement
peut-être en respirant plus lentement et
en laissant le monde venir en soi que
l'on développe sa créativité
lorsque l'on est face à un paysage
spontanément
on respire plus profondément comme si on
pouvait accueillir en nous toute cette
beauté toute cette pureté
c'est la même chose lorsque l'on est
confronté des oeuvres d'art des livres
toutes ces merveilles que la culture la
littérature l'art produisent
or il n'y a pas d'efforts à faire le
corps se détend et dans son immobilité
c'est l'esprit qui va pouvoir voyager
dans un ravin que votre inconscient va
créer rêve qui va nourrir votre
créativité 4 et d'autres sensations
peuvent se mettre en place comme le
poids de la respiration le corps est
lourd parce que l'esprit doit s'alléger
pour rêver parce que l'esprit s'allège
pour rêver le corps s'alourdit encore
davantage dans la transe et l'on sent le
poids du corps sur le fauteuil le canapé
le lit peu importe
ce dernier qui passe de tout son poids
sur le sol le seul celui de m'ancrer sur
les fondations de cette maison de cet
immeuble
ces fondations ancré sur la ville et
déjà rien que l'évocation d'une ville
cela crée on vous d'autres images cela
stimule en vous des idées des pensées
des histoires nous sommes tous et
créative
donc cette ville seulement créé sur la
terre la terre forte de tous ces
paysages de tous ces animaux de tous ces
hommes de toutes les histoires qu'elle
abrite de tous les paysages
un lieu magique le terrain de toutes les
créativités alors la terre est
solidement ancrée dans le système
solaire
le système solaire ancré dans la galaxie
la galaxie ancrée dans l'univers
l'univers de tous les possibles et
l'univers ancré dans le temps qui d'un
mouvement à toute chose et créer la plus
merveilleuse tension celle qui anime les
histoires mais aussi les oeuvres d'art à
musique et cette chose
le temps que l'on ne saurait définir ce
temps et en crémant vous disent que vous
en créez de plus en plus en transe
3 et il ya cette merveilleuse expérience
lorsque l'on plonge dans un livre dans
une bande dessinée cette impression de
laisser parler en où la voix de l'auteur
et finalement cette réalité virtuelle
peut être le nom at il mal choisie ou
peut-être l'adjectif est il mal choisi
puisque en nous c'est peut-être la
réalité la plus forte qui s'imprime
alors même qu'elle vient de la rencontre
entre les mots d'un auteur et
l'inconscient d'un lecteur chaque
lecteur et le co créateur d'une oeuvre
d'art et dans la bande dessinée qui en
plus nous offre la beauté des images des
dessins qui donne un mouvement
supplémentaire
la magie des mots et qui stimule encore
davantage nos sens puisque nous ne nous
contentons pas d'entendre la voix d'un
auteur dit avec nos mots puisque nous ne
nous contentons pas d'entendre en nous
la voie d'un auteur avec notre propre
parole mais bel et bien aussi les images
d'un dessinateur et ses couleurs
vibrantes
qui en nous à développer faire jaillir
tout le monde
celui qui aime les leçons n'ira jamais
vivre à 1000 vies voyagera partout
envisagera tous les possibles
et c'est peut-être dans les livres que
l'on trouve les secrets de nos
consciences
la singularité qu'il ya à être un homme
et pendant que cette évocation de la
lecture
pour rappel ces moments où vous vous
arrêtez soudain de lire vos yeux se
perdent dans le vide et c'est comme si
un monde surgissaient des pages et vous
le voyez devant vous et vous rêvez
tantôt simple spectateur de ce monde
tantôt acteur c'est comme si le rêve
s'échapper des pages s'emparer de nous
on rentre dans un état différent qui est
celui dans lequel vous rentrez de plus
en plus tout simplement le trans et
alors ces moments là on ne sait plus
vraiment où on est
quinon ne et le temps lui-même semble
disparaître
plongé dans la plus merveilleuse des
rêveries nourri par l'une des formes les
plus subtils de là à là
pendant que les pensées s'accroche se
décroche et que l'on rende de plus en
plus en soi même c'est à dire de plus en
plus dans le rêve dans les images de la
légèreté des pensées inconsciente
alors que l'on découvre que notre
inconscient est un océan et que nous
avons nous toutes les histoires comme le
dieu africain n 6 qui a volé toutes les
histoires qui est peut-être l'un des
dieux les plus puissants parce qu'il
sait tout ce qui peut arriver parce que
les histoires au sel toute la sagesse du
monde toutes les possibilités des
expériences toutes les idées en germe ou
parfois des idées qui prospère aussi
totalement
et c'est dans le secret de l'inconscient
dans sa rencontre avec l'art la
littérature que ce miracle se produit
alors oui à chaque fois que l'on lit à
chaque fois qu'on se laisse toucher par
la plus immersive des expériences et
bien on devient un créateur de alors qu
pensée s'accroche se décrochent
alors même que vous savez déjà beaucoup
plus que vous ne saviez que vous saviez
bien sûr parce que finalement on arrive
à se surprendre soi-même et une fois que
on oublie cette idée sortie de nulle
part et à laquelle on croit
je ne suis pas créative une fois qu'on
oublie cette idée une fois que l'on
découvre que ses yeux une fois que l'on
découvre que c'est juste ce parasite de
la pensée qui nous empêchent d'être
pleinement créative
une fois qu'on se donne le temps de se
poser vraiment et d'inventer de
nouvelles solutions pour nos vies de
nouvelles idées pour ensemencer notre
pensée et de nouvelles choses de
nouvelles oeuvres pour le plaisir des
oreilles le plaisir du goût
le plaisir des yeux le plaisir de
l'esprit le plaisir de l'imagination
à ce moment on découvre qu il suffit
d'arrêter de croire que l'on n'ait pas
créative pour pouvoir sentir en soit
simplement sortir une envie de créer
cette envie de créer qui parfois jaillit
des mains qui parfois jailli dans notre
esprit qui peut s'emparer totalement de
nous c'est la transe
c'est l'hypnose c'est ce que vous allez
développer de plus en plus dans cette
séance a les yeux fermés maintenant vous
êtes en une transe agréable et il s'agit
maintenant de laisser votre esprit
flotter avec ma voix le corps lourd de
plus en plus calme d'un côté
et l'esprit de plus en plus léger de
l'autre alors pendant que les pensées
s'accroche et se décrochent à tout
moment à chaque mot chaque évocation sur
la plus petite des inflexions simplement
contacter du timbre de ma voix est aussi
dans cette magie intérieur qui opère qui
fait que une image on appelle une autre
un son en appelle une autre et qu'il
suffit d'un petit fils tirer comme ça
le fils d'une musique le fil d'une
histoire le fil d'une oeuvre graphique
d'une peinture d'un dessin le fil d'une
création artistique artisanale ou autre
il suffit ensuite de tirer ce fil est de
construire une histoire tout construire
une oeuvre qui s'agrandit il suffit
d'une petite envie d'une étincelle pour
que le feu de la créativité s'installe
en vous et développe tout seul sans
effort l'oeuvre complet il suffit de
faire confiance à son inconscient et de
se dire que va-t-il se passer ensuite
et ensuite et ensuite
et alors tout devient simple
c'est à la fin que l'on se rend compte
que dès le début notre inconscient que
laisser le chemin et que le tout est
parfaitement cohérent accessibles comme
un cadeau merveilleux aux yeux aux
oreilles à tous les sens de ceux qui
partageront cette création
alors la manière la plus simple qui soit
pendant justement que le conscience on
dort à son rythme pour que ces veilles
l'inconscient la créativité
l'imagination le rêve autant de mots qui
finalement peut-être en hommes sont la
même chose
plusieurs noms pour un mister
merveilleux
qu'est ce que c'est que d'être un homme
ne sait pas c'est tout simplement cette
capacité à créer la nouveauté à se
distancer du quotidien de la réalité
pour pouvoir percevoir autre chose
un sens une beauté pour certains une
spiritualité
alors je vais simplement demander votre
inconsciente vous faire vivre un chemin
dans la plus jolie des campagnes ne
prend pas une fête de prairies de chant
de bois de lac d'aumar un ciel d'un bleu
merveilleux quelques nuages blancs
pommelé il suffit de commencer à marcher
sur ce chemin qui est un chemin de
créativité pour que quelque chose en soi
se déclenche
l'idée que c'est la rencontre entre
notre pensée et des choses qui nous sont
offertes au hasard de la vie alors que
nous cheminons sur le chemin de l'eau
destinée
c'est cette rencontre lilloise art qui
fait naître en nous les plus
merveilleuses idées c'est la pomme qui
soi-disant tombe sur la tête de newton
et qui lui fait inventé la gravité c'est
la méthode de descartes
perçue dans le hasard d'un rêve
et c est cette ou ces mythologies que
l'on retrouve dans la littérature et
toutes les formes d'art celle d'une
rencontre au hasard avec une étincelle
qui va faire naître le feu de la
créativité
tout n'est dû au hasard tout n'est de
l'inconscient alors sur ce chemin vous
allez faire la rencontre et du hasard et
de votre inconscient et de cette
rencontre va naître une oeuvre une idée
de changement dans votre vie et
peut-être pour certains ce sera une
musique qui va se créer au fur et à
mesure pour d'autres une histoire un
livre qui va se créer pour de votre
encore peut-être une idée culinaire tous
les sens sont dignes de participer à
l'art émérite au même niveau le respect
et la considération que l'on parle de la
création d'un parfum d'un maire
une musique d'une chanson peut dire
d'une peinture d'un dessin d'une bande
dessinée
alors les images on se précisait autour
de vous et cette campagne rieuse
ce spectacle presque enchanteur de la
rencontre entre la nature et l'homme
cette manière de créer ainsi la beauté
et le sens ce paysage de campagne
simplement qui pour vous va être le
décor d'une nouvelle création est le
chemin le processus qui va s'enclencher
tout seul et faire naître en vous
quelque chose de nouveau les images les
sons les sensations vont se préciser et
peut-être pourrez-vous entendre le bruit
des oiseaux autour de vous peut-être
ressentir et vous le contact de l'air
contre le visage une brise agréable
peut-être entendre et vous le bruit de
vos pas peut-être son tir et vous cette
atmosphère spéciale lorsque tout est
beau et que l'on observe à la fois la
nature la campagne comme temps une
partie de soi se met à rêver
cela vient comme ça en cheminant ce sont
ces moments on a envie de siffler de
chanter d'inventer de créer quelque
chose parce que soudain tout semble beau
tout semble plus facile
tout semble avoir un sens et le corps ne
se trompe pas ce corps qui se détend de
plus en plus pour laisser l'esprit
cheminer sur ce chemin de créativité
alors
simplement dans la perception de la
nature
sa beauté des animaux qui peuvent la
peuplées ou peut-être la rencontre d'un
homme d'une femme ou d'un enfant sur le
chemin
peut-être la vue d'un village d'une
ville loin d'une ferme isolée d'un bois
peut-être des auteurs d'auteur tpr et
l'odeur des champs sous le soleil
l'auteur
l'immunité a su parce que l'on passe
près d'un ruisseau clair d'une mare
quelque chose va se passer
un déclic et on recommence se créent les
premières notes d'une heure un début de
mélodies un début d'histoire le début
d'une forme nouvelle
une solution encore jamais tenté pour
votre vie personnelle ou professionnelle
la créativité peut être partout et
simplement cette rencontre qui fait que
l'inconscience mais arrivé à halluciner
finalement des choses nouvelles et on se
retrouve à trois endroits différents le
corps détendu alex terre dans la réalité
l'esprit qui marchent long de ce chemin
conscient ou inconscient peu importe et
l'inconscient lui qui commencent à vous
parler à l'oreille à laisser naître ce
début de création en fonction de ce que
l'inconscient commence à créer il faut
simplement maintenant tendre l'oreille
bien regardez bien sentir bien goûter
bien toucher même sa création pour
pas laisser se précise et grandir
devenir plus belles davantage chargé de
sens de force d'énergie
il y à cette sensation nous sentiment
qui va être l'énergie qui développe
cette idée pour en faire une création
comme il est bon comme il est facile de
prêter attention à son inconscient
lorsque le corps est détendue et que
l'on est
refonder mans en transe comme cela et
j'aimerais que vous observiez
cet arbre loin majestueux pour certains
ce sera un chêne pour d'autres un
olivier et peut-être ne le savez-vous
pas et c'est souvent près des arbres que
l'on croise les muses les filles de zeus
chacune consacrée à un art particulier
de la poésie à la peinture
et ses muses ont ce pouvoir singulier
inspiré le coeur des hommes et des
femmes de faire naître en nous des
choses les plus sublimes
alors je vous invite à vous rapprocher
de cet arbre majestueux et à observer la
merveilleuse créature qui s'y trouvent
peut-être une belle jeune femme otage
elle qu'on représente les muses
peut-être un animal comme une sorte de
totem qui pourra vous parler peut-être
envie ya peut-être un enfant peut être
autre chose peut-être simplement le
bruissement des feuilles qui vous
racontera une histoire qui vous jouera
un morceau chantera une chanson
asseyez-vous près de cet arbre et
laisser la muse vous parlez laissez-la
de ces mots habile de ses mots chantant
de l'évocation poétique de ses
métaphores laisser là
créée en vous la peinture d'une nouvelle
création
ne soyez pas étonnés si cette création
se précise davantage si elle trouve de
nouveaux rebondissements nouveaux
détails
s'ils gagnent en force en beauté ou même
parfois en simplicité pour pouvoir
toucher le coeur des autres c'est très
bien comme ça
et maintenant
que vous avez fait la rencontre de votre
muse vous allez pouvoir vous diriger
vers ce village
un peu plus loin là bas il ya une grande
et belle place qui vous attend une scène
a été dressée
vous pourrez vous y asseoir et en
fonction des outils de votre art que ce
soit un ordinateur un stylo
un chevalet avec une toile de la
peinture simple papier un crayon à
papier simplement un lieu pour chanter
danser créer un objet une oeuvre d'art
sur cette scène se trouveront tous les
outils dont vous avez besoin pour créer
et un public fait de personnes que vous
appréciez vous apprécierez à qui vous
aurez envie d'offrir vaudra car il ya
cette chose un peu mystérieuse qui fait
que la plus solitaire des créations est
toujours une oeuvre offerte à tous
approchez vous de cette place observez
saboter la tante bienveillante de ces
gens ils sont venus pour vous pour ce
que vous avez à leur offrir
je vous allez pouvoir de honteux
partagez votre art partagez vos idées
partagez vos solutions de vie ce qui va
être étonnant c'est que cela va jaillir
tout seul si vous utilisez des pinceaux
les mains auront l'impression de peindre
tout seul la toile de se remplir d'une
seule de couleurs et de formes
si vous jouez d'un instrument les mains
elle aussi pourront courir tout seul
porté par l'inconscient sur l'instrument
de musique et fait renaître la plus
belle des musiques la plus puissante
les choses vont se faire tout seul et
vous allez pouvoir observer la richesse
intérieure qui préexiste en vous
se développer grandir
et s'offrir aux yeux de ce public qui
vous renvoie quelque chose de doux une
sympathie respect l'admiration de la
gentillesse peut-être tout simplement
dont les yeux et les coeurs les oreilles
voit de plus en plus créé par votre à
vous allez pouvoir continuer ainsi à
travailler sur cette place à offrir le
plus merveilleux des secrets intérieurs
la richesse de votre inconscient ne suis
pas étonné si au détour de vos journées
détail une personne un paysage une
rencontre tout d'un coup fait penser à
ce lieu à sète hypnose et créons vous
une nouvelle it et encore une autre
encore une autre ne vous étonnez pas si
en pensant un arbre un chemin dans ma
compagne à la place du village
votre esprit inconscient fasse naître
directement une oeuvre une envie le
début de quelque chose qui prendra forme
presque à elle même
mais je vais vous laisser là dans le
secret de votre coeur dans la sérénité
de votre inconscient sur cette place
avec ces gens en train de travailler en
faisant le plus beau des travail celui
de la création est resté autant de temps
que vous le souhaitez à travailler ainsi
tout ce que vous allez créer va rester
en vous disponible lorsque vous contrer
tout à l'heure de 1,5 pour sortir de
transe et lorsque vous le souhaiterez
lorsque vous aurez suffisamment
travaillé à votre goût à votre
convenance
il vous suffira de contes et de 1,5 pour
revenir ici dans le temps présent est
conscient riches
fort de tout ce que vous avez créé que
vous allez pouvoir emporter avec vous et
maintenant je me tais
pour laisser place en vous au travail et
à la création
sept séances de bien-être vous a été
proposé en partenariat avec le fit aux
nuits le fit aux nuits en sachet à
infuser un mélange innovant de
mélatonine l'hormone naturelle du
sommeil et de cinq plants pour
s'endormir et bien dormir
bonne nuit avec le complément
alimentaire fit aux nuits